>> Shannon: ALL RIGHT.
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S POINT MAN FOR
THE CRISIS IN VENEZUELA SAID
DISPUTED PRESIDENT MADURO WILL
FALL.
RUSSIA IS CRITICIZING THE U.S.
FOR TRYING TO OUT OF THE
GOVERNMENT OF VENEZUELA.
HERE'S THE STORY.
>> CONTEST THE VENEZUELA
PRESIDENT MADURO'S
VICE-PRESIDENT IS IN RUSSIA.
RUSSIA SUPPORTS MADURO.
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION SAID
ALL OPTIONS ARE ON THE TABLE.
>> I DON'T WANT TO TELEGRAPH OUR
PLANS TO THE REGIME.
PEOPLE WERE TALKING ABOUT
AMERICAN MILITARY ACTION ARE THE
RUSSIANS.
>> THEY ARE PURSUING A PEACEFUL
TRANSITION WITH ECONOMIC
PRESSURE.
THE U.S. IS REVOKING VISA OF
MADURO OFFICIALS AND THEIR
FAMILIES.
>> I CAN'T PREDICT THE DAY THAT
MADURO FALLS AND LEAVES
VENEZUELA.
IT MAY BE THAT 3 DAYS BEFORE
PEOPLE WILL SAY, OH, THE ADT
ADMINISTRATION POLICY FAILED AND
BOOM, THERE HE GOOD.
>> MADURO INVITED ABE RAMS TO
MEET WITH HIM.
HE IS COORDINATING WITH A
LEADER.
>> I RECEIVED THREATS TO MY
PERSON AND MY FAMILY.
THREATS OF BEING IMPRISONED AS
WELL BY THE MADURO REGIME.
EVEN SO, THAT WON'T REPRESENT BY
RETURN TO VENEZUELA.
>> ABRAMS SAID THERE WOULD BE A
BIG REACTION IN VENEZUELA.
ABRAMS GOT CRITICISM FROM A
FRESHMAN CONGRESSWOMAN.
>> THAT'S A RIDICULOUS QUESTION.
>> YES OR NO?
>> NO.
>> I WON'T RESPOND TO THAT KIND
OF PERSONAL ATTACK.
>> ABRAMS SAID HE IS THE
CONGRESSWOMAN HAVE NOT SPOKEN
SINCE.
>> I DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT WAS
ALL ABOUT.
YOU WOULD HAVE TO ASK THE
CONGRESSWOMAN WHAT HER INTENT
WAS IN THAT COLLOQUY.
>> THE ADMINISTRATION WARNED
CUBA OVER ITS SUPPORT OF MADURO.
THE ADMINISTRATION IS ALWAYS